the Wanda vision Marvel Disney show is
going to be quite possibly one of the
most different things that Marvel has
ever done based off of everything that
we know so far it's not going to be like
a typical Marvel show or like a typical
Marvel movie it's going to be quite
different and it seems like we know why
as it turns out the wand of vision
series could introduce a major Doctor
Strange villain the one and only
nightmare according to Charles Murphy he
has heard that nightmare has already
been cast and will be the main villain
for Wanda and vision but he will also
tie into Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness and be a villain
in that movie as well and this actually
lines up with a plot leak that we've
heard for the one division series not
too long ago with a little bit of a
twist to it also if you're new don't
forget to subscribe but notifications
turned on like the video and leave a
comment for your chance to win an Xbox
one or a ps4 so the leak that we heard
before about the one the vision series
for starters said that it is going to
introduce their kids speed and Wiccan
but it also said that Wanda is actually
going to be in some sort of different
reality and this reality is going to be
created by Agatha Harkness but now
according to Charles Murphy from
Murphy's Law podcast who has been right
about a lot of scoops lately he says
that it's not going to be Agatha
Harkness but it's actually going to be
nightmare that creates this alternate
reality and this makes a lot of sense
and it makes much more sense than Agatha
Harkness being the one that creates this
alternate reality because we have
already had confirmation from Kevin
Feige the president of Marvel Studios
that the one division series and Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness are
going to directly connect with each
other meaning that the events that
happened in Wanda and vision are going
to directly affect the events that
happen in Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness and nightmare
makes a lot more sense in this setting
because he is a major Doctor Strange
villain and let's not forget that the
director of Doctor Strange Scott
Derrickson has already mentioned that he
wanted nightmare to be the main villain
of the second Doctor Strange film and
then the film's writers see Robert
Cargill had indicated that the next film
would probably feature nightmare as the
main villain so nightmare being the
villain of the Wando vision series is
kind of bringing that to fruition for
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness and nightmare creating sort of a
fake alternate reality for the scar
which makes a lot of sense that's just
what nightmare does but this could
actually be setting up dr. strange to
have another villain and that villain
could be the Scarlet Witch herself and
the reason for that is because this
alternate reality that she's going to be
put in is supposed to be the perfect
reality for her vision is supposed to be
alive and well and he's supposed to be
human and of course in this alternate
reality she also has her twin voice as
well
Wiccan and speed and it's supposed to be
like an old sitcom they're supposed to
be this perfect family but we also heard
that the kids are supposed to age very
rapidly they'll go from babies to
teenagers within the course of just a
few years so that's a pretty big
giveaway that whatever is really taking
place in this one division series is
probably an alternate reality and the
problem with that is eventually Wanda is
going to find out and when she finds out
that it's all fake that means she's
going to find out that vision is not
really alive and that she really doesn't
have kids The Scarlet Witch in the
comics is known for being a pretty
unstable character now she does go
through a tremendous amount of trauma
but ultimately she ends up losing
control multiple times
she's even responsible for creating an
alternate reality herself in the House
of M series which is something that they
could be leaning to make happen in
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness because if you think about the
title multiverse of madness there has to
be a multiverse and it has to be very
chaotic and it is probably the Scarlet
Witch that has something to do with this
so the Scarlet Witch at least for a
portion of dr. strange and the
multiverse of madness could be a villain
now of course Doctor Strange will
realize that this was all nightmares
doing and from there he will figure out
a way to defeat nightmare and hopefully
bring the Scarlet Witch back but based
off of what we know so far the Scarlet
Witch could be a villain and Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness so
we're getting a major villain from
Doctor Strange in one division and then
that villain and possibly the Scarlet
Witch as a villain we'll be heading over
to Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness to take on Steven strange
be sure to comment with your thoughts
about Nightmare entering the MCU and the
Scarlet Witch losing control as well and
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe with notifications turned on
so you can enter my giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 if
the winner gets to choose as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof